[Music]
so let me jump straight into it we take
first three minutes of spoken speaker to
give a short thesis on this question are
we fascinated by evil characters because
they make life more exciting and Terry
you have the floor first
why is evil so sexy why so glamorous why
is everybody talking about gothic why
does the devil have all the best tunes
why would everybody want to share a
whiskey with Fagin rather than orange
juice with Oliver Twist well I think the
short answer to that is that evil
becomes sexy when virtue becomes boring
and that's a historical matter in the
16th and 17th centuries was the rise of
Puritanism
and the middle classes in general the
middle classes are always rising virtue
is redefined as thrift prudence
temperance chastity and so on now in the
light
since nobody wants to be good in that
way if that's what good means you don't
want to be it then that's the moment
when evil becomes glamorous it's a
historical matter because it wasn't
always true if you look at certain
ancient thinkers if you look at the
greatest theologian perhaps of all time
Thomas Aquinas for Aquinas virtue being
good is exciting and exuberant and it's
the way you flourish and it's the way
you express energy and evil is lack
deprivation nothingness negativity and
inability to be fully alive an inability
to flourish it's flashy but it's phony
it's empty it's boring
evil is paper-thin and without depth and
it's boring so there's a whole
turnaround historically which ashes in
the modern epoch Aquinas thinks that
being is good in itself creation is good
it's good that there are squirrels and
telegraph poles and razor blades and
glasses of water around the place that
is good
the demonic is that which is anti
creation which is dedicated to reducing
creation back to chaos it's a reversal
of creation back to a kind of pure
nothingness and purity is very seductive
not least for fascists and there's
nothing more pure than absolute
nothingness the demonic is a kind of
anti creation yes it's scoffs at human
meaning and value at the pretentious way
in which we take our meanings and values
so seriously it's deeply cynical and
nihilistic it's Iago in the face of a
cellar yeah and it desires nothing more
than to debunk and dishonor and deflate
the petty pretensions of humankind
that's why the demonic is a kind of
sniggering and cackling as it is in the
greatest novel modern novel about evil
Thomas Mann's Doctor Faustus
the demonic wants to smash all that he
wants to return us to the pure nihilism
nothingness and he wants more over
precisely to do that surely as an end in
itself not to any instrumental reason
but to use a theological term just for
the hell of it yes just for the hell of
it and that's one reason why evil is
extraordinary rare thank God
very rare because most wickedness is
instrumental you your wiki or your
immoral for certain purposes right evil
is that very very strange kind of
wickedness which is in it just for the
game which once just destroyed as an end
in itself and having summoned up that
incidentally is connected with Freud's
death drive to reduce everything to
nothing what some people call obscene
enjoyment and having summed up the whole
of evil I will now either leave or
so Susan I'm sure your dare venturing
through other aspects of evil well yes
but not without saying that I'm Terry
Eagleton just showed why I agreed to
take part in yet another discussion of
evil because Terry Eagleton was going to
be part of it I find him always both
eloquent and deep and sick as I am of
the subject I mean look at this I
basically agree with everything you said
but I want to go in a slightly different
direction look at this I was in the
discussion about sex that took place
just before this it was full but it
wasn't this full this is standing room
only and it's interesting to think about
the way Christianity
Christianity's puritanical views about
sex may have put the sex into evil I'm
not sure that that's the case what is I
love Pope Francis you think I bring on a
tangent but I'm not I'm a Jew by the way
but I love post Pope Francis because
every single religion is made up of a
set of moral Commandments one has to do
with you know who you sleep with and how
often and what parts of your body you
cover and the other has to do with how
you treat widows and orphans and the
poor and it's normally a mishmash of
both of those things I think Francis has
separated those two so that sex is just
not part of morality in the same way
that concerns for is a weekend the poor
are and I think that's a great a great
service if it takes some of the sex out
of evil that's an additional service
I've come to think in thinking about
this question that the reason we
like focusing on evil is actually a
really bad one it's to to steer our
focus away from the real sources of evil
which are what Hana aren't called banal
that is they're not the things that are
done with evil intention they're not the
things that are done with a pure wish to
annihilate simply for the hell of it
there are things like climate change
which take place actually without too
many people intentionally meaning to
damage anything whatsoever and if you
look at cases of genocide the sorts of
things that you know I traditionally
looked at in cases of evil
you'll also find very few people I mean
very few people in Germany were
genuinely interested in murdering babies
and old men that's not what they signed
on for they saw known for other reasons
and it's very important to look at that
so I think that we we like to focus on
on these sensationalist characters
because it keeps us from focusing on the
evil that we should really be worrying
about which is that which takes place
without anybody's terrible demonic
attentions thank you very much
and then we have
[Applause]
and you Steven what's your take on the
question I don't like to disagree with
what's been said here which has been
boring in a debate of course I promise
to disagree a little bit later on what I
want to do right now is just give you a
different way of thinking about this and
I come from it not as a literary
theorists not necessarily as a historian
but as a analytical philosopher
philosopher sorry no philosophy and the
question is why are we fascinated by
evil well first of all I'd like to make
a distinction philosophers always make
distinctions and and the first things I
want to make is between evil persons and
evil acts because I think they're quite
distinct they're related in some way but
they are distinct you can have evil
persons who don't commit evil acts and
you can have evil acts that are
committed by a non evil persons so why
why we fascinate with evil and evil
persons in particular well I think the
fascination is really a way of
expressing our our sense of horror at
what these people are doing why is that
because we all live in structures in
societies we all live and depend on
other people to have the kind of lives
that we have our well-being as depend on
other people behaving in certain kinds
of ways towards us that's the basis of
morality it's the basis of manners it's
those kinds of issues are very important
to us and we know that there are certain
things that people can do that will make
our lives
intolerable will make any decent life
impossible no matter what it is that you
think your life should be why would it
be impossible because as Stewart
Hampshire one of the great moral
philosophers pointed out there are
certain things called the great evils
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you